[Music]
available
[Applause]
something soon
[Music]
good luck
Oh
bedrock
[Music]
you can see the distance forever chris
has gone hey buddy wicked speed Simone
and they're listening a good time for
Steve's mom and I'm hanging out with my
pally hi um putting up my headphones
because somehow it it sounds different
wha it's one of those weeks how was your
weekly I had a really a fun week I got
to go awesome I got to go to Vegas which
was one it was it always fun give a
client there now I guess it was I it was
a one time thing so far but I hopefully
will turn into more that's great but it
was just uh when I was a kid just the
idea of a business trip seemed cool yeah
it seems very grown-up you had to me
like I don't know it's different from
vacation because we vacation czar always
cool but just like the idea like oh I'm
gonna suit like they pay my plane ticket
I'm going somewhere I'm going somewhere
else different it's fun it wasn't it was
only the Vegas but it was so much fun
and then even better last night I
thought of you there was a little boy in
the West Rosen haha wearing a cape rah
just like a regular hero cake did you
see that picture the three little
brothers wearing capes I don't think so
was it was it in them it's on there
somewhere it's on the regular hero
Instagram these three little kids were
so cute thank you to everybody that came
out to the regular hero blood drives for
people i want to help our mission
helping others their website is regular
hero org we need all the donations we
can get because it looks like our big
fundraiser is going to be postponed
because we got David Spade to do it but
now he's going to Hawaii okay well that
sucks there's so many people that need
the money I ran into a woman at
children's hospital last week who works
there was the sweetest woman ever and
then I just turned out her kid was just
diagnosed with cancer oh my gah my gosh
god it's just so much I'm exhausted to
be honest with you it's uh exhausting
yeah it's exhausting and it's it makes
it a it's tough but that edits it it
makes the little things I don't know
makes me appreciate things a little more
Oh
and I'm so grateful that I have the
opportunity to give back and help but I
need your help out there that help me
help you remember Jerry Maguire guys
even if it's five bucks just send it to
regular hero dork because there's people
out there that really really need it you
know like I'm so grateful and blessed
for the life that I have it's an
absolutely amazing and that's what this
podcast really is all about like it's a
celebration of life and I'm so excited
with this week's cats have finally got
Jackie Kashian on here the host of a
dork forest she's so cool and awesome
her new CD just came out it's called I'm
not the hero of this story and it went
to number one it's all got excited for
like for some reason I just see you and
Jack occasion as like childhood best
friends go we would have definitely been
fractured he's so cool and then who else
did I get this week all I got Peter from
a king of New York Pizza that donates
all the pizza for our pizza parties best
be journalists dude he's so so cool he's
such a good guy and then uh Kirk Fox
anyone hear something awesome I do I
don't know what I'm allowed to saying it
okay I've been with okay I was with run
as easy when I got really good showbiz
news as with steve byrne when it got
really good shoulders and smooth and I
was with Erik Griffin when he got really
good she'll but Eric's got to get on
this podcast Erik Griffin when he got
really good show business news and
yesterday when I was hanging out with
Kirk his uh he had his phone off but he
got a really good phone call while we
were recording the podcast so between
that and the time dice was teaching me
how not to gamble in vegas and he hit
the slot machine for ten thousand
dollars I'm convinced I'm really good
luck I was gonna say you might want to
not say like in this town people might
just have hiring you as I hang out with
I hang out buddy this will be like so I
get a big business deal on the line
let's call Steve that'd be great just
hang out look your positive energy to
people yeah I think there might be
something to it's so cool so I'm look so
excited about these podcasts and that
i'm going to record with big Earl Skakel
I think Tom I rera the legend said he
would do a podcast with me so there's a
lot of good guests coming up and once
again saying that you guys support this
podcast by using the amazon link on
awesome Steve com
that's how I get to pay for Lee and if
you guys you keep on using time more
stuff maybe I'll be able to make some
money off this podcast but I'm just
grateful to do it because I liked
meeting you guys I like hearing your
stories and gotta be honest I'm like
it's kind of like virtual hanging out
you know what I mean and it just gives
you a reason to hang out with your
friends just hang out and turn your
phone off for an hour yeah just hang out
with us on this podcast let's get into
this episode Lee it's the very funny
Jackie Kashian oh this is funny we were
talking bleep I don't know you know how
if we do our gratitude list at the end
of the same absolute and like I've
always they would like I would say stuff
i'm grateful for plumbers and things
like that we were talking about plumbers
on this podcast and then i think from
that point on I heard the faucet running
in the bathroom it was so funny because
I couldn't really concentrate from going
should I get up and turn off the faucet
I think somebody left the faucet on so
it was hysterical the absolute best all
right we're hanging out with Jackie
oh that is awesome I'm not the hero of
this story awesome where can people find
the album it's on iTunes and Amazon okay
and it's that card it's a drop card oh
cool that you can just if you're in a
country that doesn't have itunes and
amazon it some of them don't have the
amazon for some reason yeah um you can
email me Jackie Jackie Kashian calm and
then paypal me some money and then we'll
figure it out that awesome I think that
cards like this i'm getting to a USO
tour in may I want to have cards to give
you time a bunch of that stuff too
haven't you got a little I'm always
willing to do more just for a couple of
reasons one is because nobody's more
bored than deployed yeah soldiers and
Marines and sailors or whatever because
there's a lot of a lot of time to worry
yeah a lot of central time were you in
the service no I well cannot but but we
know a lot of people on yes so many my
friends were like yeah the ones I used
to work at a one of my day jobs was
working at a gym in Hollywood okay down
in Venice so half the people I met just
at work or you know people actively in
the military or just retired right or
inland or in the National Guard yes and
so many my friends and there's nobody I
respect more you don't know what a
teacher's military here's the weird
thing is I went in not knowing what the
hell like I'd go on these there they
were armed forces entertainment 14
Jacqueline right and I I went in not
knowing anything because my father was
in the Marines but he was really in the
Navy some maybe medic oh my god he's a
hero well except for that he's my dad
how do us another hero isn't it weird
that you can't see your parents
objectively I I see my dad super
objective hahaha i got IV like I think
one of the funniest things that I want
to play around where medically like I
know somewhere right now there's an
assassin sitting in a living room in
this kids are whatever dads are such a
dork you know if you can't wait right
amazing sniper in other news we're out
of ice cream yeah hello exactly right
yeah so but what I did not realize
because why I mean I was not raised in a
family that was it was important to be
of service okay which is funny because
my father was in the service and that's
what it's called it's called being in
the service so i would have to say at
least ninety eight percent of people
that I've met on that different kind of
tours of performing for the troops yes
I'm leery of the word tour because of
because there's people work on tours and
yeah people are living among rubble
anyway intense so but but I 98 at least
an eight percent of their people who
join the service to be of service they
wanted to be of some use yeah and
there's a couple of people that are just
like well you know you're never safe
unless you're next to me feeling my
muscle and and even people in the
service know that that guy's a douche
baguette yeah and once that you're like
Jim's all right in a fight you try not
to be alone with him now my one friend
was like this right he was like hey man
you know there's certain people that are
so stupid they'll get you killed it was
like yeah did not but no you want to you
that's not your buddy yeah the guy you
want to be in the he's like he's ok but
you don't want to be standing next to
him when it gets it goes down yeah if he
wants to shoot dogs yeah cuz he's got a
giant gun and they're like no no man
we're not here to give a read a
generation kill no but did they adapted
that too in HBO's here right I never saw
this I never saw the I never saw the TV
show I didn't meet the guy wrote it oh
wow and um he rode in an MRAP you know
or whatever uh in two thousand three or
four Baghdad with a recon marine troop
which shouldn't have all been in one
truck because they're Recon Marines and
their supposed to be parachuted ahead
right yeah but for some reason the
general was like we're going to send all
the Recon Marines in trucks whatever
these battles
to essentially trip all the oh god all
the ambushes and you're like well if you
dropped us in we could maybe disarm the
ambushes from the other such no okay
well I guess we're just driving in and
and one of the guys that was um was in
the blowhole like I'd like out with the
but it did it yeah he kept saying stuff
like hey there's a camel I'm gonna shoot
it and the Corporal who's in charge of
the truck was like we're not here to
shoot camels uh settle down and as long
as a dog I go she's like we're not here
eschewed keep it together yeah so I mean
there's the second but genuinely
ninety-eight percent of the men and
women I met were amazing better make it
better like I my first tour was about 11
years ago mm-hmm and I was like pretty
depressed i'm going to be honest and I
was just like at that point my life oh
my god everything's thanks everybody
stinks like I was just suited whatever
and then I got to meet some of those be
and I was like oh my god just great
people in the world yeah like it's just
better people they made me should human
being who want to be doing something of
uris yes yes yeah like I remember my
first trip to Afghanistan and I remember
meeting a guy who was like I'm here
because I have two little girls and it
was like I would love to influence this
society in a way where the little girls
of today can be educated and one day
vote and being a part of the government
I don't know what disguise amazing he's
a superhero yeah yeah it's weird um we
are we supposed to get us in and then
the week before we were supposed to
leave they killed bin Laden and then
they said hey comedy is cancelled in
Afghanistan we're still go to
Afghanistan I was like fair enough and
they had we don't know where you're
going but it's not Afghanistan and I was
like wait what if I don't want to go
anywhere now because I'm scared yeah and
they said no no you're still going to go
somewhere but we don't know where and I
was like did I enlist and way it was
fine we went to Africa where I did not
know we had troops oh well then we were
an hour here did you go to be white
booty we went to Djibouti you may search
your own joke right those guys I did
them a favor didn't tell that joke when
I was but
yeah and would the I don't know why but
that because I went though it had to be
like seven or eight years ago now but
this young marine came up to us after
the first show in Djibouti and said hey
are you coming to Kenya I would love you
in Kenya and I was like I don't actually
know where we're going neck I don't
think it's Kenya and he goes well we're
not really there anyway but I was like
hey dude I'm a comic with a Twitter feed
once you sip it together we can even
shared it on my and everybody silent on
my album I was like I think the people
of Kenya should know that the United
States is again yeah we're everywhere we
got a lot of loose soldier it's like
Lulu and but I and so often the sort of
the fact that there are American
soldiers everywhere means that when
there's a national natural disaster yes
they're the first one who can help you
absolutely and it's amazing and I asked
I mean there's a whole picture there but
as because i am a libtard snowflake
leaving hardly flm welcome to my poli
sci degree from the University and I'm
in anarchic socialist is what I think of
myself as I wish everyone would choose
to share yes everyone isn't choosing to
share we might have to legislate some
sharing anyway um everything I mean to
learn I learned everything I need to
know I learned in kindergarten
essentially and and nobody calls
five-year-olds with a libtard social
ahahahaha what isn't that a fascinating
down being that progressive and your
pull and then you meet the military
people yeah wait a second right and my
dad like I said was the regime but he I
come from a long line of cowards were
runners man one of the first things he
ever taught me as a kid he's like you
get to fight you run and he said you get
you can't run distract and then run yes
but that's actually the same advice
someone to my toughest absolute
gnarliest friends like who like fighting
maybe add there was one guy my buddy big
Dennis was like a lifelong martial
artist and he was a huge man
was big Dennis yeah yes and then he like
I wanted him to show me martial arts
like this was in my early 20s was like
come on dude yeah and then he was like
all right this is what you did when he
got my fighting stance down and he's
like now take your right hand swing it
this way turn your hips and running the
other day yeah she was like it's never
worth it it's worked out every single
time that one time I picked a fight and
I was I think 12 yeah and I picked a
fight with a nine-year-old girl I am a
girl and I thing this one I should be
winning this one and I should be buried
headfirst in the sand and my feet
painted with honey for picking a fight
with a little kid huge difference in a
nine year old and a 12 year old yeah
ever hear when your kid matters it
matters and she beat the [__] out of me
I'm sorry spectacular haha the thing is
if she beat the [__] out of me because i
was and i genuinely believe this whether
it's true or not I was wrong yeah I rely
my heart wasn't in it yeah she had right
on her side yeah and we gave her the
strength of 10 men yes no or whatever I
will hold yes and she helped out and she
beat me up and I never picked I never
did it again learned lesson learned I
actually had a bad and I have told the
story on my own podcast the door for us
by the way I'm Jackie Kashian and we're
going to do it i was going to do an
intro be over fair enough yeah and so
the like three weeks ago you know we
live in los angeles and so like three
weeks ago there was a supposedly i read
that there was an immigration checkpoint
right by my house oh my god and i said
to my husband hey I think we need
laundry detergent I'm going to go to the
grocery store and he's like and we had
my in-laws were over and he goes just
for laundry detergent and I said there
might be a nice setup on Van Nuys so I'm
going to go to see if I am needed as a
white lady meat shield and any is like
well I love you for even caring enough
to do it I will watch my moms and so he
stayed and I went down essentially
looking for trouble
and with like with this little girl yeah
I went looking for trouble there was
nothing there it was gone or it had
never been it just been like one of
these things rumor so I go to ralphs I
go to the grocery store and I because
I'm out my hair right I'm walking out a
relf in front of me is an old man I am
NOT the hero of this story because I
pushed an old man ah I didn't push him
down I won't protect you to push an old
man here's what happened ah right
because this is not okay nobody not okay
not on any way level any that I could
all people are my favorite well and
there's any this is a bad guy but
there's still no reason to do it and
there are other ways that I have learned
since I've talked to others who were
like hey guess what other ways you could
have dealt with that walking on a ralphs
and this guy he's got to be 80 and he's
not homeless he's not crazy looking he's
not hurt looking anything he's wearing
Dockers and a belt and a polo shirt
carrying a loaf of French bread right
normal looking very old man and he walks
by we both walked by the rent-a-cop and
the rent-a-cop guy is black and he
starts yelling at the guy in calling him
the n-word Oh Helena he's from Haiti and
that that's why there's aids and he
[__] are you crazy not having to
sweetheart security guy at the ralphs up
on burbank is yeah i love that guy yeah
i talked to that guy every time i go to
ralphs ten o'clock and that guy the best
thing about this story was that guy just
laughed in his face awesome because well
except for that it means that happens
three times a day to that [__] case
which is the sad part but um it's
terrible but I lost the tiny lizard mind
and ten years ago I would have just
yelled at the guy and said oh hell is
your problem yeah in this case I got his
face and I was like no you hunk a junk
this is not okay you don't say crap like
that and I just I got this and I was
like what the hell is your problem and
all this stuff right this is this you at
are you already fired up before you left
the house right yeah and we're in a
weird time right on racism and bundling
people up into trains and sending them
into the desert to kill them isn't my
greatest fear so but the and brown
people is who's going anyway so uh and
so I got in this guy's face and he said
to me it's
your business this has nothing to do
with you let it go and I said it has
entirely everything to do with makes I'm
an American absolutely and we're here at
and he said ha America and I turned into
a country music song hahaha and pushed
him and that's where I was like hey get
it together walk away walk away there's
no pushing of the elderly and I was told
a couple of things they could have done
is gone and talked to the security guard
rent-a-cop guy and said hey man that guy
is an anomaly and whatever you need you
talk to that guy or I could have said to
the old guy if I needed to can you hear
what you're saying listen to what you're
saying out loud out of your face and say
that to him until he is driven mad and
just follow him to his car going did you
hear what you said the jira which are
set out loud and I was like I didn't
either of those two things yeah which
means uh live and work right yeah crazy
though so sad like I I actually feel bad
for the old guy in the story for just
thinking like that oh no what is here
after he's a lot of terrible way to go
through life you don't I mean like
whenever I get angry with people I step
back and usually my anger turns to pity
either that make sense for a lil think
about how much a life he's missing out
on or did miss out on right it's well
it's there's the parallel with that for
me because I tend to like whatever you
know when you park illegally and you
think I tried rarely I'm very early or
or you've lost your keys your lost your
wallet yeah and you're like well I'm
screwed yep it I make it so big in my
head there's a committee meeting there's
a parade and I have in its practice
right yeah got it is you have to take a
step back yep interrupt that thought you
go wait a second calm down yes this will
suck yes it is not the end of the world
you will figure out how to get more keys
who will figure out yeah how to get more
ID you will cancel take and I tell you
that's the best thing about for me that
I found about getting older or I'm like
oh wait a second think of everything
you've already survived this is me I'll
paddle yeah i think that big of a deal
else is that big breath and
weirdest thing is if it the the relief
is bigger yeah when you see it and that
sort of the happiness that I feel when I
say oh I found it yeah see I did not
need to lose my mind because there it is
listen and it would have either been
there any way or not been there and if I
would be all in a tizzy I would not be
happy at all and yes sometimes I check
myself where I'm like you being an idiot
and I start laughing at myself those are
the good day it's in it's a learned it's
a learned task learning everything in
with yourself and with others and all
these things and yeah I haven't lost my
temper like that in years so with that
old guy so there's that much me that
Simpsons when Homer was like you have to
take your emotions and press them all
the way down and then sometimes they
just come out like remember when Daddy
through the whiskey bottle at the
referee said like that's one thing like
I from my crazy family me and my
brothers we called the invisible fuse
yeah that we would like somebody's fuse
and nobody would acknowledge that
behavior thing was bothering them and
then it would just explode out of
nowhere all the invisible few visible
fuse one of them lit one of my brothers
calls it whenever anybody storms out
because we all drive separately we
always drive separately to every event
so that my brother Phil always goes just
in case someone needs to have occasion
like moment where you can throw down
twelve dollars for your entree no tip
and store them out so that other people
have to cover your tip hilarious yeah
I'm just getting better at acknowledging
stuff one like a man this isn't cool so
I don't just snap out or no yeah and
what it probably was you've probably
been pissed since the election and you
see how things are going back and forth
and how we forget we like I don't
believe in politics but what drives me
crazy when we don't see the humanity and
others yeah we don't work em come on man
well the first line of this new album is
traditionally I have not been a
political comic but I am now yeah
because I'm alive yeah we I am a human
person watching two percent of society
leads thirty-three percent of the lemon
yeah into possibly doing terrifyingly
horrible horrible things you know like I
never thought we would be the bad guys
in World War three I would not have
called that right yeah and um we are
heading down a weird-ass road that I
can't live in that future either no I
have to live in the president of mouth
and make sure that I help the person in
front of me that's it that's what I
that's what I put on my laptop album I
was like turn off the TV mm-hm just be
loving and kind to everybody you mean
get out of the screen yeah Idol screen
yeah and into a human pair of eyes yes
and it is the greatest thing ever yeah
yeah it comes you back and I had a great
talk I do a bunch of work with a
Children's Hospital I've been blessed
that way and one of my little buddies
this kid was he's a miracle that he's
alive and we celebrated his sixth
birthday two weeks ago it was awesome me
and his parents are Mexican Americans
and when his dad was returning from
make-a-wish its family went on a
make-a-wish trip to Florida for disney
me too and it was a grateful for the
election and they got on a plane and as
a guy wanna make America great hat again
drum pad and I was like I bet you if you
actually had taken the time to get to
know that guy you probably have a lot in
common and there's no and he was like to
see if that's exactly what happened he
was like I made sure i sat next to him
and he was like this Southwest yeah
what's helpful yeah it was like we had
the greatest conversation yeah we saw
the humanity and each other we talked
things out me was like we like most of
the same stuff and we all pretty much
want the same stuff right that guy just
what doesn't want the corn canning
factory to go out of business what and
he's not he's not the bees not the
problem I mean the people who got
tricked into this or the and it's just
it's it's a snowball that just we got to
make sure it does not run out of Deborah
I I think we're so blessed because every
night we're in front of what i love
about comedy yeah it's a how diverse the
audiences can be yeah like and the most
open-minded people in the world because
they have guys you might want to youtube
google your comedy because you've walked
into and it makes them the most
open-minded people in the world cuz
people
walk into comedy clubs Cory hey I'm
gonna see comedy yeah and you're like
you don't know what kind of car you're
gonna see you might see mean comedy you
might see Pratt fold yeah even more
diverse than music it's in the car you
know for sympathy symphony and
Metallica's on stage you're gonna blow
this right this was not what I wanted
yeah and with comedy no there no no I
mean there's not like hey I'm going to
see hip hop hey I'm going exactly you're
like oh it's a black guy I wonder what's
going to happen right or Oh ladies here
I wonder what's going to happen but
straight white guys are just as diverse
within straight white guy and so you're
like oh straight white guy I'm a
straight white guy I wonder what's gonna
you're like if no no it still could be
weird and it's so subjective comedy it's
more subjective amazing more subjective
than taste buds because I don't like
people will actually get angry where
they're like that's not funny I'm like
just tried their best like there's a lot
of controversy right now with a bunch of
comedians with people like although
arable that Ryan was stout for months
googled the words comedy and trouble or
lovely garden area and fired or
something and it was every day at a Duke
aid though he's an episode of the dork
forest where he just talked about it it
was fascinating idea to the North
morning but I think it's the best thing
is when people are just going there for
comedy in quotation mark we have the
opportunity every night to build bridges
to remind everybody that we're all
connected because that's our job yeah
like there are the type of stand-up
where I'm not like if I connect with an
audience it's going to be great but if I
don't connect people can be like life
this guy talking about his life Oh in
tears I am the golden retriever of
stand-up comedy nobody doesn't not like
me even my dad one time I dad said
people know your big pinko commie every
year get any guff about that and I said
Dan have you looked at me have you
looked at me recently people look at me
and think what's she going to vote I'm
terrified and so I mean nobody I look
like everybody's aunt or their their
roommate from college where's oh it's
you know even when I went overseas you
know I used to do this joker tell the
story about um how a bunch of my friends
here in Los Angeles really usually
surrounded by hot 19 year old guys and
you're like have you ever been
surrounded by
hot 19 year old guys is a lot like being
buried underneath the litter of golden
retriever puppies uh I it's exhausting
but adorable it's adorable but
exhausting and I mean this is not a milk
I am NOT a cougar this is lady who makes
a good pot roast if you miss your mom I
will give you a hug so area it's fine
and it's a great mission in life by the
way there's nothing wrong with that
mission and it's it's not i mean the
mission is to make people why yeah but
what we were talking about was is I like
how if you're really conservative or if
you're really liberal whatever those
things mean to you right yeah and you go
to the comedy club people would go to
see comedy are more open minded and
they're like why not agree with that but
it made me laugh yeah and they're like
that guy seems like a dick but he's
funny or she seems a little bit of a
hothouse flower but I'm on board yeah
you know and you just you laugh if it's
funny yes and if it isn't funny to you
you can leave absolutely there's it
turns out there's a bar take a lap not
cashell father did no true yeah it's and
people do like the first 15 of that 12
maybe 12 of our my new album are um or
jokes that I've only done six to ten
times oh cool I have never put anything
that raw on an album before this is my
fourth album okay the following 45
minutes are the jokes that I have been
working on for the last 45 for last
three years okay two and half years so
um so those in those first 12 to 15
minutes are political jokes because you
felt it needed to be said right it was
six weeks after the election yeah
everybody was relatively just kind of
stunned going on what the hell is going
to happen nobody knew so and i am very
egotistical and i wanted to make sure it
got on the elbow yes so cuz i don't know
what where i'm going to be before the
next album yes i opened up my albums of
brand new bit too because i was like i
just want to remind us that we're all a
mistake away majerus drop ah december so
i had recorded in october was rightfully
right before you and I was like look man
we're on
together we're all connected don't
believe that's great that's not it and I
told a couple of stories about that and
then we were off to the races mm-hmm and
then he did the rest of your jokes right
cuz we're just up there talking to
people yes the coolest thing ever it's
the greatest job in the world it is the
absolute best I mean how long did you
want to be a commitment I never wanted
to be a comedian I wanted to be an actor
when I was a kid we never listened a
comedy when I was a kid we listened to
motivational speakers because my father
is a Salesman Bigler man sell the sizzle
not the steak dealer is actually kind of
great by the way is great he's not he's
not a bad guy guys just used to sales
guy and he doesn't want he's not selling
yup you know buggy ride led to know
where is nothing he's like you just
gotta you want to get a product and you
sell it you got to believe in the
product and and the product is is
whatever you believe in yeah and the
rest of it is how you sell it and he's
like I don't necessarily want to sell
the thing you want to sell but I can
tell you how to sell anything that you
believe it you have to believe in it
reminds me that story reason when you
were 12 in the little girl with nine and
like I lost the fight I knew I was wrong
I kind of feel that way about sales or
comedy where it's like it took me a
while at the comedian to grow to the
point where I could say exactly what I
felt on stage yeah I wasn't trying to
get to laugh which I guess would
correlate to trying to get the sale it
was like no this is what I believe you
know the first three or four years you
just want to get laughs you want to get
reaction to some extent yeah a fan of
comedy and then and then after that it's
why when people who are new you watch
the comics that you love right well I I
never did when I was a kid but there are
people who have grown up now who love
like Zach Galifianakis yes Sarah
Silverman yeah and those guys six seven
years ago we're doing like this ironic
racism thing right or other comp nick de
pollo and does this sort of real
hard-ass kind of hard edged kind of me
you know and what he's been doing it for
20 years correct and so can do it you
know if you open up and then other
people who are talking about like
they're like Maria Bamford she'll talk
about her mental illness and she'll talk
about
other things that are hard all these
comics that you admire that's great it's
very hard to start your career on your
holocaust joke right if you might be
Jewish you might have been you know
attacked as a child and horribly maimed
and you think it's funny because you
lived through it right and by the way
you're right it is funny now that you've
lived through it and there might be a
great bit there yeah but it's like
Picasso learning how to paint an arm and
then going on to cubism absolutely so
it's yeah i mean the to dissect it to
death yeah i love it yeah i loved i
second yeah so is it rely to a painter
on here who's also a comic the sky
taylor balls his stuffs incredible
that's me and he was like yeah you have
to make sure you get you can replicate
reality before you start to you just
have to have the holder skills to some
extent yes like if you can it's muscle
memory at some point yeah and then you
can dive into your weirdest thoughts
like look at louis ck that guy talks
about sort of very much unwanted
thoughts like he's got three or four
bits that are about just creepy thoughts
in his head yeah and you're like oh and
he can do that because he's coming the
necklace well and he's yeah cuz he's
because he's been doing a 25 years
exactly it's it's he can come to it he
knows where the line is crying so hard
like when I talk to my nieces and
nephews and they're trying to be funny I
was like it's a learned skill it was a
learned skill and you got to learn when
line is and ya hurt somebody's feelings
you're not going to hurt somebody's
feelings and that's the line i remember
reading an interview with Chris Rock and
he talked about the really really
controversial stuff that he liked
because I guess certain people to like
wool this is what I really want to talk
about but he said it was like kind of
like mixing nitroglycerin he was like if
it's off just a little bit it's going to
blow up and it's not going to work let's
take it which is why I think the longer
you do stand-up you want to mix my
nitroglycerine yeah
because you're like a challenge it it's
the thing that that makes your hearts
are pounding you're like I'm going to
try to do this bit yeah I got a couple
of those bits on the Left album now
about sexual abuse and and my husband is
a game designer and so we sort of
reframed this sexual abuse thing that
happened to me using LARPing live action
role playing which is like every it's a
costume party with costumes is a costume
party with game mechanics and because
he's a game designer and everything has
a game mechanic absolutely everything in
his life he's like what I see what
you're doing there but like I once got a
text message from from jury duty and he
said this game is broken and that's
awesome it was hilarious but um well the
the crazy it's just he's he's wonderful
and it's it's yeah there's there's just
there's so many layers to it that yeah
I'm sure it's true with plumbing I mean
and I keep you I keep mentioning
plumbing in all these interviews but I
love plumbing I would love to know how
to do plumbing the coolest thing ever i
have a buddy of mine who uh he's general
contractor he can fix everything and
anything and i'm fascinated by that I
mean that guy yeah I love hanging out
with them and like because like I would
dig in the YouTube video tonight and
whenever I would get stuck I'd called my
buddy Kevin and now I just look for
stuff around the house my Kevin grab the
tool let's go do something cool father
yeah it is and I don't know it's pretty
it it would be so great to be able to
fix stuff and I know the laws are going
this poop involved and you're like
that's not what I'm looking for what I'm
looking for is that noise that doesn't
make out of the pipe exactly it's
tangible results and I know as a comic
okay i love standup comedy yes my theory
is this life can be so challenging and
difficult that if you can make somebody
laugh you have a moral obligation to do
so I believe that that's me I really do
believe in and I've noticed that people
that really are more self actualized
even at plumbers like if you can do that
what a great skill that is to offer the
world right plumbing it's amazing is it
amazed
using skill I know genomics that don't
really do stand up anymore move to
Washington DC now their plumbing
companies build over a million dollars a
year right well i mean it's its
resources to print money that plumbing
gigs but i'll tell you and they have a
very nice they have a very good union so
people can work on guys you're retiring
for everyone entering union till night
out there oh so with the world need to
get on him absolutely there's i met a
woman plumber the other day and she said
one of the great things about the union
was that it's entirely merit-based
awesome so if you were a good woman
plumber it doesn't matter that you're a
woman you know yeah that's what's so
great about it it didn't flush before
now does it is success yeah and the
difference between with comedy it's like
what we do we go out there we r onstage
yeah then it's gone and it's like you're
you have a feeling they have a feeling
but what what can you really touch and
that's why i love like we fixed my oven
yeah fix my garbage disposal fixed my
shower yes my toilet we fixed my car
last week and you're like didn't work
now it works now or expects me it is
tangible it's none of those but the
tangible pneus of fan of comedy is the
immediate satisfaction of telling a joke
in getting a response yes and then what
that's also be CDs yeah that that's
three years worth of work yep right
there and I people who want to do like I
know Stanhope does a lot of CDs in a row
in a year or whatever or per year Mike
Kaplan will do a lot of them and Louis
CK famously was doing them for a while
yeah and a lot of British comics will do
it too but my jokes don't actually work
like that they take that I will start a
joke and it will be a six-minute joke
and it will get whittled down to two and
a half or three and a half yeah and
everyone should appreciate the fact that
I don't put out an album everybody here
no worries right come see me live you
can watch me work on that's what I think
it's the coolest thing yeah comedy lives
the cooler it's the best it the way I
like it comedy live comedy on an album
and then any kind of video I agree with
that yeah just because the screen can
separate you from the from the from the
even the oral
yeah you're more connected to it like if
you're just listening to comedy you you
could picture whatever you want it's
like reading a book it's like even
listening to a book yeah so coolest yeah
like I remember as a little kid like I
love standup I never thought I could do
it but I loved it and as like an 11 year
old kid 12 year old kid I by that point
I had watched Eddie Murphy delirious I
don't know forever right and I realized
what I thought made him great i was like
he doesn't give you the picture he gives
you the dots he just gives you enough
we're in your brain you make the
connections between everything oh man
this is the coolest thing ever why did
you think you couldn't do it I thought
you had to be born special I didn't take
a normal kid from the suburbs of
Philadelphia was allowed to enjoy their
life that much Oh interesting how does
[__] that yeah that's harsh man that's
rutul well I felt like show business
people were just born different
interesting somebody explain to me
probably six months ago what I do
another podcast about just entirely just
the minutiae of span of county serious
and who do you do that with Laurie
Kilmartin softshell jacket laureates on
the Nerdist Network oh and it is it's
just us bitching about stand-up comedy
and just going down a rabbit hole of
that cool very popular with comics and
would comedy nerds people who love
standup and but Lori explained to me
like six eight months ago what imposter
syndrome was you heard of him mouth
syndrome first of all sword syndrome
anyway but impostor syndrome i guess is
something it's common among women and
minorities or that you think you're not
valid enough like you get the job but
you think you're not worthy of it and so
if you don't ask for the race you don't
ask for the promotion you wait to be
offered two arrays and offer the in
promotion even though you're doing the
one job and you could probably learn to
do them at yeah right so that's called
imposter syndrome and you feel like
you're an imposter you have this great
job and you don't feel worthy of it
somehow and are crazy it is crazy
um because we could all be taught simple
task absolutely uh yeah yeah it's fine
monkeys can be taught to do most things
don't worry about I just think robots
are going to take over just not every
bring any way to take the job figure out
how to do it guess what if you can't do
it you'll find that out too and then uh
it's an honestly just about 90 about
smartest guy I know told me this once
and it rings true like ninety percent of
everybody of every profession always
that good at it right right i have
ninety percent of it is showing up on
time yep she's getting the job yeah
please get there on time and then you'll
be fine I know my dad told me that about
Ivy League colleges he was like sheep
the toughest thing is just getting in he
was again i want to go to Penn knock it
out for two years at Dillon / 111
transfer in did you do it no you didn't
have an interest or it did not enough
because here's what my dad was uh I was
literally raised to be an imposter
literally would bother be like now you
can do whatever you want my parents did
tell me that and I believe but I just
saw comedians like well the truth is I
did open mics in my very early 20s but I
just had to get enough misery of my life
to go okay this is the only thing I want
to do ok but like as a little bit job
wise er yeah I felt like comedian pro
wrestler soldier of fortune I thought
these were all the coolest ways to go
through life when I was like can you
really do that and ever mitzi sure I was
her assistant for a year and she started
laughing she was like now all comedians
think that until they try it oh yeah and
the thing about stand-up is if you want
to try and do stand-up trip yes you will
know immediately whether you want to do
stand-up comedy and it hits people at
different levels of course but what I
did it I was 19 and I it was a heroin
yeah and I was like oh this is what I'm
doing now yeah and I got a 1.8 that
semester why luckily the club burned
down and so I grade whether you could go
home with your life right so I go on
with my life and I and my sister was
like well now you could finish college
because she is the boss of me and I was
like God is going to drop out and just
go to comedy and she was like it's
another three more years and I was like
okay and then next year she said it's
only another three more years I'm not
great at college isn't so what was
Madison life he's great it's uh you know
I went 80 for 288 so a lot of Reagan and
and I studied Poli Sci because in my eye
was 83 to 80 85 years so I was like
three years in and the counselor called
me into the office and said you must
declare a major and I was like what's it
look like and and I think it was a guy
because you have one more credit towards
graduation in poli-sci than you do in
history and I said well that I I'm a
Poli haha that's awesome and most of my
poli-sci was not domestic it was
southeast asian studies for some reason
and armaan fascinating yeah have you
been to that part of the world no I've
been I went to Hong Kong a couple of
years ago just to do stand-up but that's
not even that's not Southeast Asia so
it's uh but i want indonesia in the
Philippines and Malaysia have always
been place of Monica I've her again the
most beautiful places on earth have a
good friend is Indonesian who it's
working on the cure for AIDS by the way
I asked her how it was going and she
said not good not good haha every time I
see her boy how's that cure for AIDS
coming along she's like that better than
cancer at least we know where it comes
from yeah and I was like well good for
you early steps baby steps the journey
continues steady work and uh but she's
funny cuz she's from Indonesia American
ships and her husband who sadly just
passed away but from Japan financial
advisor guy American citizen their son
they named him hon and they named him ha
jus like you guys are always culturally
appropriating our names we're gonna
cultural approach for appropriate the
Germans oh that was like Hans and she
was like yes I like it Hans taka Nora or
whatever last name is no that's like
where I grew up was just about everybody
at least in my little region of the
suburbs was either Jewish italia
irish so so to be these great
juxtapositions would be like Sheamus
catan 3d you know what I mean I straight
name Rocco O'Leary we were German Polish
and Armenian there was some Italian like
if you branched out in other words it
was and I found this out cuz there's a
woman who does fan of comedy in
Barcelona cool Rachel RAF and my father
sells aluminum siding and we've always
looked at in a grubby Dangerfield we're
at yes except for you Sophia um uh South
Milwaukee Wisconsin a little factory
town outside of Milwaukee between sort
of milwaukee and racine okay and rachel
r EF dad's old woman of siding and he
was from a northern suburb a northern
town just north of milwaukee named Fox
Point Wow and her father I didn't have
six children and so was about much it
was a little cheaper yeah my father very
successful six children he would have
had to have been Mel Gibson you know so
have I think I children and have a bag
of money as a doorstop so Rachel RAF I
think just has a brother so they were
able to have you noticed that and I'm
not saying this to kiss your ass I
noticed people that come from big
families always cooler we're good always
cool you know why because you can always
ignore to talk to you until you can
ignore and then you can rotate all that
and I'm the only one who talks to all of
them I am like the youngest and sort of
like the the Andy my husband calls me
the hub and you don't get a call how's
Tara doing I was like he's fine you
could call him and ask him about it
right and they're like no no just
checking in really just checking in with
me about a guy that you could easily
pick up the phone right yeah here two
bedroom with for 15 years okay fair
enough it's where is amazing yeah I'm
but that's also very common comedic
trait I notice comedians are the people
that sort of like keep their family
together one way or another right or
they're complete out guess yeah it's
like it's sort of like two or that's the
person I wanted wanted to be or have the
you know what I mean I do a lot of stuff
about my family I'm uh on the album's
and/or in my act I guess would be the
better way to not make it an ad get out
there but the like when i recorded this
once a week after i went to Milwaukee
where did you record this I always
recorded my home club attack me in
Minneapolis coming to Calcutta that's
where I came up and it's almost
impossible to get into acme unless you
grew up in the system you are famous or
you are famous adjacent ok almost
exactly like the comedy works in Denver
yeah yeah true it's a beautiful room but
you gotta grow up in the system you
gotta be famous you had a big favor to
Jason yes so there's a couple of towns
have just run it like that yeah what are
you gonna do yeah but that's cool you
just means it's good yeah and it means
if they they care about their local
scene which is the most I mean yeah good
yeah yeah it's a pain in the ass if you
are not from there or famous or a famous
adjacent but i think is a big picture
and you're like no yeah i will create
better comics and then we a see better
comedy and then comedy will continue to
be a thing correct it is no big picture
yeah i think that's one of the best
friends welcome to comic too it's like
if you're not getting the opportunities
then you wanted ok just make something
better right you get what you get yes I
mean the thing is is and that's fine
it's they can't stop you from doing
stand-up comedy it was what I did last
comic standing the first year the one of
the but you know there's he's produced
the cameras in your face like a reality
show right yeah and they didn't have a
lot of questions the second season I
think and they just know what's easy was
but it wasn't the first thing and so the
director or whatever that person would
be called I don't care kept saying to me
um what happens if you don't win and I
was like well I continue to do stand-up
comedy I've i'm going to i don't know if
you know this i'm going to chicago next
week anyway so that's fine the first 35
times you hear it yeah once it'll like
yeah 175 part of my brain started going
what's gonna happen if I don't win this
content God which was I'm furious to
this day that they put that anywhere in
my brain I never had stage fright before
I went in to do Last Comic Standing I
never I would get nervous yeah it was a
nervous energy that would create fun yes
right that that you channel that nervous
energy to go this is exciting let's go
do it yeah I get to the Last Comic
Standing the one of the final sets I was
in the top I wasn't in the top ten i
wasn't i didn't make the house right and
build wire went out before me great
comic so he comes back and I'm just
standing backstage just sweating and
having all kinds of bodily functions
which no dog could be blamed upon and so
but Bill's wire comes on stage he grabs
from bro my shoulders and it goes get
this you get out there it's just stand
up comedy oh that's awesome it was
awesome he was like what a good dude
just start talking it'll be fine and I
was like thank you that's awesome so I
went out and it was fine and yeah there
was but after that I would I remember I
froze up on stage twice huh and it was
once was a corporate mmm that was
disappointing for the people because I
had a brain freeze in the middle of it
but that was so it was the second time
it happened and that's what I realized
how to deal with the stage fright and
since then it it's it's mostly
dissipated and if it ever happens again
I know how to deal with it which is I
physically move if I take a step to the
left of the right I've moved my body
which moves my mind yeah which unfreezes
my tongue which is what I use to talk to
the people that's awesome yeah it is all
sort of connected right right huh so so
I don't know if any of your listeners
get that kind of thing but just to take
a small step just kind of and laugh at
yourself ago all right yeah i remember a
comic that was kind of like a mentor to
me when I was like okay I'm going to
really try to do this he told me once he
was like whatever you're thinking just
that
a legit he's like it'll put you back in
the moment yeah in the moment with the
audience it was like yeah would have
been funnier had you said that and said
and I was like okay cuz I walked off
stage I was like oh and it was like you
should have said it yeah that would have
been awesome he's like so from now on if
the thought comes in say it right I'm
like okay cool there's no script you oh
you're writing it yeah it turns out the
coolest thing ever yeah it's really
great are you the only funny one in your
family no no I'm not everyone that by
the way is hilarious and second of all
when I first started doing stand-up
comedy my stepmother famously said to me
in my mind famous you're not the funny
one Ross is the funny one and i was like
that out loud to my face and then I said
you know risk can't be the handsome One
and the smart one and the funny one he
doesn't get to be all the things I I
know he's the golden child but I'm
taking this one yeah so and he continues
to be the golden child but everyone is
funny and my family so the back yeah
except for my oldest brother who for
some reason found Jesus and Jesus took
funny away from him and jammed it into a
coffin and shoved it up his ass Terry I
love you but Jesus Christ shove it i'm
pretty sure that Jesus I no one is up
for last first miracle was turning water
on the line let is it the party guy guys
I used to do this bit about how because
the thing is is I love Terry and Terry
is a good man and but he has also a kind
of mean like for some reason he's got
the meanest Jesus my I want him to wear
i would love to him to write a
children's novel a children's book
called the meanest jesus because my
jesus always says like good try I will
do that again right and his Jesus always
says all we're gonna have to burn you
yes and you're like uh no we were both
worried it's in the same church which
was all in Armenian so uh you don't know
what they were saying either so you
could take it as anything hilarious I
worked for an Armenian woman out here
for years I would sweetest yeah oh good
yeah that's it that's a good end of
excess she loved me yeah she totally
loved him awesome
yeah just thinking about her right now I
ask that you never think of people in
America you know what I got to call them
yeah I got to give them a call I thought
about my I had a therapist for three
years what I want to kind of first moved
out here and my therapist she was great
you know she helped me um she was she is
probably so she might be like 90 now but
I don't know she seemed older then
anyway yeah so but uh she was she had
the funniest name of her book her name
is Helene Z which I think was just added
because there's a lot of Helene Harris's
okay her name is Helene Z Harris and she
wrote a book 20 years ago called are you
in love with a vampire and I used to I
used to go Colleen you know that's the
funniest name of any book ever in the
world of self-help that's hysterical and
she said you know what it means not
right I was like yes I get it it means
an emotional the employer and she's like
yes yes hello it was it works yeah
exactly she's dead such and such a great
late she was a wonderful therapist quite
honestly she used to do in the 70s used
to do sex therapy in Los Angeles all the
stories you know Oh sex therapy nude and
she said in the late 80s she stopped
being nude and everybody she was like I
realized a couple of things she said I
realized first of all I didn't look as
good nude as I did in the 70s and two we
didn't need to be nude look how would I
need that's the type of thing like
people in philly when they think about
all those wackos out in California
that's exactly what they think of well
when that happens when I first moved out
here like probably six eight months and
I moved out in like 96 or 97 one time so
I got a call I was talking to my dad and
he said he gone a lot of those Hollywood
parties and I said nope not really
Hollywood party type bed and there was
just pause he goes good good hows it car
running and I format to that exact I was
like well you're adorable and that's
awesome yeah what I'm fascinated by
everybody's first year in Hollywood we
worth crazy was it yeah it was dumb um I
had my first job as I was a secret
shopper at different grocery stores food
for less i bleep kidding it was not paid
about five dollars a store and I had to
dive to each of them it was one of the
lowest paying jobs either get the food
for free two dollars and fifty cents per
/ grocery strapon I'm imagining like
here's a fifty dollar gift card buy
whatever you want ya know go from store
to store and you have like yeah stocked
kitchen nope and then and then I started
temping and then I got a job at a cold
caption company that was great but the
thing is and I will say this i'm glad my
sister made me graduate from college
because i get a better class of a shitty
day job because the glass of crummy day
job goes up if you have a degree so my
temping I got better pay for it I got
better you know and you're not slinging
burgers I doing a hot dog stand for
three years three summers and Cape Cod
um in I was like 8780 or 88 89 and 90
was it anything like that movie one
crazy summer with Bobcat Goldthwait you
know I never saw that long I saw about
last night savage Steve Holland remember
oh he's a wrestler no its director Steve
Holland did like better off dead one
crazy summer that's fine i'm pretty sure
one crazy summer second Cape Cod okay I
i worked at a footlong hot dog stand at
a gay resort town called the
Provincetown Massachusetts and footlong
hot dog stand you know what joke never
gets old to really drunk gay guys put a
condiment on that that's just good
writing the writing you guys it was a
nice it was a different time anyway
whenever anyone says it was a different
time I'm reminded you know Chad Daniels
I know the name he don't rate kamikaze
apolis and he's a delight and he has
this joke about his grandmother I don't
know what Alton son but us about his
grandmother being racist and everyone
kept telling him well you know she was
raised differently you know she was
raised differently with a different time
she was raised differently and him
saying you have a cheese raise now right
she'd grown up now could she get her act
together because she's an adult now
right and I was like and then there
might be another punch line but that was
my favorite line of it because I was
like that's just the greatest way to
confront your old racist relatives yeah
I remember Joe Rogan saying well he was
like if they're at jerk now Chancellor
there were jerk then and nobody ever
checks them and I remember he was
talking about another comic in
particular they had a rough childhood he
was like hey man I get it and I
understand that but he's like
everybody's been through something he
was like there comes a point when you're
an adult that you take responsibility
for who you are interactions and how
they affect people are you listening
Batman Jesus Christ they died when you
were seven you cuz I've had someone on
the door for us I'm just going to add
two about to work far so you get a lot
of comic book dorks on there not as not
as many as you'd think but I had a bat
mad dark on who was talking about how
just think about how much good Batman
Bruce Wayne could have done if he would
have just opened up two or three
factories in Gotham oh that's hysterical
instead of putting on a cape and
millions of dollars worth of stuff and
going punching people in the face good
job health care right he could have bled
off all of everybody's henchmen
everybody's henchmen would have had jobs
exactly yeah better schools left crime
overall education genius was not
flipping had to anybody written that
that's funny yeah I don't dash quit get
a little book that would be so so funny
I still all right dash and feel of some
of the San Francisco comic dash
Kwiatkowski came up with that plan
thanks Christ what inspired you to do
the dork forest I am I did a joke in the
late 90s early 2000s about how deep you
I had to go because I'd hang out with
anybody yeah but I was thinking about
how deep i had to go into the dork for
us to get to someone I would hang out so
that was a term that's awesome yeah and
then I would name a bunch of things and
then so I just started this broadcast in
2006 and it was I
Center and I everything's got a dork
come right so whatever your thing is
that's the door come I did Will Anderson
about cricket I have no I know nothing
about corny will and as that Wells the
British are aliens oh right he's
Australian and he's a great australian
comic will anderson and he explained
cricket to me for an hour and for an
hour afterwards I knew how cricket was
played and then it's like I think this
week's episode is with Michael Powell
sick young comic and he talked about
Harry Potter let's Korea or was awesome
and last week was my kaplan and he
talked about ayahuasca and I was like
whenever anybody want to talk about a
drug or a sexual position I'm like is
this really this is really a dork them
yeah seemed like the coolest gun guy OB
llam did he wanted to he said my dork
comes our sex and we'd knock you're not
a dork I was like first of all almost
everyone loves sex and weed I don't know
if I this very few people and then he
opened his trunk and showed me the 30
different strains of weed that he has
and I was like oh you're okay yeah yeah
and then then we just talked about how
much he likes sex so uh guy opium a
Sacramento comic so I have a lot of so
cool that you put on these comics and
you give them like comics from I
everybody you mentioned is not like la
base yeah right an awesome yeah I try to
I try to do when I'm on the road I try
to get the feature on just because it's
yeah so great yeah yeah just because
everybody is a dork about something and
I try to get fancy people who don't get
me wrong right uh and but i also like if
you're a fan of the show and scheduling
scheduling is the hardest part of course
yeah you can be on the show so I've had
this woman who does quilting in San
Francisco is like what are you comin
when he coming up to San Francisco and I
was like I don't know but I do want to
get you I want to get you all there's
also a ballroom dance dork up in my area
but i did i was on this boat with 1,700
nerds this last week perfect and I could
have done 1700 hahahahahahaha I couldn't
face it I was like there's got to be
some down time you guys
corded six episodes that's often six
hours of listening and it was
photography Saturday Night Live Oh
musicals genealogy eyeball scuba diving
and escape rooms so that's awesome yeah
so they can be traditional kind of dorky
think so comic books and video games and
movies Oh a real butcher is a comic from
here and she did the three back to the
future movies so awesome w kamau Bell
did like a scene-by-scene of rocky too
oh that's awesome I was just listening
to the rocky 2 soundtrack at the gym
today Carlos always Ronnie to the
exorcist you know I'm such a dork I'm
afraid to see that movie I've never seen
the action yeah my god it's not
happening yeah that's exactly how I feel
like that I don't need that in my life
you've already scared me congratulations
yep oh wait what's the title of that
film okeydoke don't need to see it I
wonders and fourteen dollars to peel but
I'm never seeing get out it's not
happening it's look what Tara now I know
everybody says it's so great but soon as
I found out it's a horror movie yeah I
don't like the parish yes I don't want
to be scared I'm good yes don't work it
out I would like a happy yeah I have I'm
very limited time to spend on stuff and
I want to feel better about life I went
to Logan how is that Logan it's a
Western essentially it's cowboy movie
with an x-men or two awesome and it's
it's incredibly well done on a non-gypsy
unforgiven one of my all-time favorite
movies of all time if I have amazing
dorky sheriff's badge that like they
give you a blockbuster who did it and I
begged for it everyone groaning us
please Unforgiven is an amazing film
when that wind model drops I'm like oh
oh somebody's got to get to that house
that he's building holy smokes but gene
Hackman oh so good everybody kills it in
that movie yeah measure twice cut once
yep that is not the work of G neck but
who I always think of as a rich man
Dabney Coleman haha
haha which is not to a fit when I was a
little kid I would get confused but over
certain actors had a similar look and
Bobby I wait a second what does that one
say may I it is not I saw nothing to be
done I used to get it was three people a
judge reinhold and Steve Guttenberg
mixed up and then and then I would get
them both mixed up with Michael Keaton
until he did Batman and I mean what did
you see the founder with Michael Keaton
know so that it's about our a crop but
Michael Keaton kind of killed it in
every facet you could like silent every
kind of yeah yeah you stand up comedy he
was really really good that's right he
was a comic F yourself and up yeah and
then his comedies like mr. mom hilarious
gum ho Batman awesome mm-hmm I didn't we
need he's over or whatever it was dude
and now look he's great in the sky so
freakishly talented you know he's sort
of like he's more like Steve Carell you
know like an old-timey Steve Carell
old-timey 20 years ago whatever but um
but see girls the kind of comedian and
actor yeah that could do drama and I
think there's these guys that you
there's actors and actresses obviously
actors who you can just pour a script
into and they become that person yeah
who's um Michael Douglas I was good he's
the guy did you see ant-man no that's
the one superhero movie I've yet to see
it's what I love the Avengers so now I
want to go back and watch it is a door
with a Civil War one I think it's one of
my favorite of them all and I just have
a lot to our strange eye on the ball of
course did you need akhter strange all
right yes I thought in 2d and in 3d
assamese because he's a sorcerer supreme
you're gonna want to see that in 3d so
why wouldn't you so we've hit the hour
so you're looking at your watch I your
time with a try to be subtle it's okay
absa name your album once again why not
I'm not the hero of this story and as of
this recording it made the Billboard
chart oh that's awesome congratulations
thank you it's never been anywhere near
any of those charts itunes amazon
billboard it was on itunes of amazon for
three days number
that's on which means that it gets to go
on to the Billboard chart it but when
this airs even if it airs hours from now
it will no longer be on the Google hair
that's what a win uh yeah don't think it
didn't take a screenshot yeah I guess
don't really get totally took a
screenshot okay and dork farce where's
that force is my podcast it's on all
things comedy network.com I want to
totally come on but i'm a dork about so
many different grammar we'll do it we'll
do it at anything okay doesn't know i'm
a dork baseball cards pro wrestling
pizza yeah everything weird I make my
own Oh excellent odd you have a shown
yeah or did you just buy a tile no no no
I have the stone and I import the flower
from Naples well we're going to talk
about pizza and then i have the dark
forest podcast which is just door for
calm and then pardon me and then i have
the comedy one on Nerdist with work in
Martin call Jackie moreshow that's
awesome and up awesome awesome awesome
well thank you so much if this was
awesome all right thank
back yet
[Applause]
so guys that was Jackie Kashian once
again her new comedy album you can get
them iTunes you can get it on Amazon it
is I am NOT the hero the story that's
Jackie Kashian up trying to find her
Twitter really happen to have jackie's
twin I didn't want it looks you're way
smarter this stuff to me her twitter is
it's at Jackie Kashian it's jay ack IE
in keishon is KAS haan and right now her
her name on of his apocalyptic magoo
hilarious that's so funny and she does a
great podcast called the dork forest and
you can subscribe to that and that is
PDF the dork Flores podcast and then
it's at dork forest pod on Twitter I'm
always seeing her once doing a stand-up
but it was one it was at the improv in
hollywood and I've never seen her before
they know what to expect and just she
just uh it was like so unlike surprise
it like that's why I love going to those
kind of clubs for that is we can like
someone who supplies is he was hollowed
money back oh it's almost great comedies
coolest thing ever I just looked on the
Instagram because it's we're recording
this on saturday night guys so i have to
head over to the comedy store and i just
saw that i get to bring up run is easy
on stage Chris it goes Chris Spencer me
when is easy da my rare and Marc Maron
how incredible is that that's a great
lineup it is insane if you see them do
you start thinking like what am I going
to say to bring up Steve's and I like
maybe I'll say something goofy or do you
know I always take it way too serious it
like you know you never try to mess with
anybody or just now I like giving people
the business it like not to it you have
to be professional will people get mad
at you based on the internet on people
do Wow okay I figured out figured
comedians would want to be silly and
goofy especially with their friends now
some people have really serious they are
so funny like if they have a stinky set
they blame the person that introduced
them written it's maybe just did stinky
yeah where you just had a bad night yeah
it happens oh that's funny huh funny
business and I cut the comedy business
you think people would be a little bit
more relaxed you would think oh I'm
grateful that you are very goofy and fun
like to have fun I like that laughs I'm
very grateful that I was given the
ability to make people laugh because
it's the best you make so many friends
that way I'm grateful for just an
elegant like movie theatres comedy clubs
I love laughing was like a bunch of
people yeah this is it the energy of an
audience it's more a guy microcosm of
life Lee we need each other I think I
got it better that might be the next
step for specials because i love
specials and I've seen some great ones
but it just does i think maybe that
maybe we have to have start having like
group watching parties or great idea
humming that's a really great idea yeah
because that's that's the whole thing is
seeing other people laugh oh there's
always one lady in there who has laughed
she's probably embarrassed by but then
I'll have oh I there's no laughs that I
love more than the supply surprise last
is the greatest you know what I wrote
down this week and it's tied into that I
love like when I was little I I always
wanted to be the deep voice guy in a
barbershop quartet or doo-wop group or
pretty little under logs I always wanted
to be that guy and I love like when I'm
at church or something and somebody
that's near me that you would never
expect they start to talk like say a
prayer allowed or something or father
and their voice is all deep it's my
favorite so funny and awesome I wanted
that voice to look the TSA guy in the
vegas airport had it yesterday which i
thought was weird that do they do it for
like a special emphasis or that you tell
you know some people that just their
voice that's what just makes it so funny
do you work to be over laughing charge
by mistake did I it's the best kind of
laughed their energy laughing when
you're not supposed to laugh is extra
fun with a view is it was like yeah yet
people like or do you like sometimes if
I my brother's would always trip we'd
always make each other laugh and my big
brother had this technique where he
would start to laugh and then he would
stop he was pretending so then he would
just do it so you describe act like that
and then I would finish his laugh and
then I would get in trouble she even
Anthony
Chris left no I didn't he was acting
inappropriate brothers the easy greater
evil geniuses I love mm-hmm I'm grateful
for just go on we'll go back to the
intro I was seeing that kid running
around in a cape the greatest never like
the coolest cake I've ever seen it was
like a full red cape he was just just
killing it and then I also like I'm
grateful for when kids know that they're
being cute those are kinda there's a kid
in the elevator who is like every time
someone else going on he looked up at
his parents and go we can't fit anybody
out and people just are laughing and
he's like he's like I'm killing it I
might get on it you just kept saying it
looks like a mask wishes or at best oh
so much fun and Alexis fun just grateful
to be here man I'm grateful I'm grateful
that Paul is making cinnamon rolls right
now how great is that homemade cinnamon
roll that's incredible you know what I
might do for cheat day tell me my god
I've heard I don't know if this is
certain but if her du par's has the best
pancakes in the world I've heard that
too you know what I went there once and
I didn't get breakfast was pretty good
it wasn't that bad so I think I'm gonna
check that out speaking while we're on
the top of the food i want to send a
special shout-out to the Don Carlos taco
shop in La Jolla California act for Ryan
I want to send a shout-out to didn't go
to italian deli in Chino as for Carlo
and King a new york pizza in Koreatown
answerer Peter they're all good guys
through all small businesses that a go
out of their way to give back like a
triangle of happiness I'm delicious food
yeah it really is you meet someone in
like Anaheim or someone someone write
down like Islam portillos hook me up all
the squalor that would be the grade of
portillos would complete the square of
deliciousness we I got to get over the
hill to the comedy store I want to thank
everybody for listening please continue
to use the amazon banner if you haven't
checked out my CD what's up nerds please
do so and i'm grateful that you're all
here listening thank you so much take
care god bless will be back next week
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
I
you
[Music]